first I'd like to thank Lauren and Anna
excuse me in the Hollywood Walk of Fame
Committee for this incredible honor and
God I should have I probably should have
said God first show tonight but where
I'm not sure who was more important in
getting me this honor I know it was one
of them I and you know what I'm gonna I
know that the I've heard the committee
is really powerful almost omnipotent so
I thank them I thank them all I I would
like to thank Tom Carson Priscilla
Presley David Foster feather incredibly
kind words and more than that for taking
their incredibly valuable time to be
here with me because they made it even
more special
they made the moment even more special
for my family and I today thank you
[Applause]
they also they also made me feel
important really important and that was
no small feat today my record being out
today and having a star here on the Walk
of Fame
I have personally never felt so
self-important before I it's funny you
know I I want to get off this because I
struggled with this today
and I think everyone in this business
probably struggles with not mixing up
who you are with what you do and trying
to separate your ego from your spirit
because there are two very different
things and on the flight over here I
sort of had an epiphany and I realized
that out of all the wonderful
celebrations or honors that could be
bestowed upon any entertainer this may
be the greatest opportunity to truly
know that it's not about you
it really isn't David said it in speech
but this isn't false humility it's the
truth
it is truly about all of you beautiful
people because I never be standing here
without everyone you know
today's a day for those people to have a
sense of ego and to know how much it
means to give selflessly like that and
to give their experience to give their
love to give their support my mother and
father who are two of the greatest
people in the whole universe who have
taught me kindness and empathy through
their deeds through their actions my
wife who there's nothing I can really
say that that can express how I feel
about her and what we've been through
she is my hero and my rock my children
who have given me a purpose for life and
have made days like this even sweeter
because I can truly understand how
beautiful the good moments are hi I want
to thank my manager Bruce Allen my
friend my partner whose dedication
support and belief in me has taken us to
a level that we never I don't think
thought possible I know no one else did
I would like to thank my fellow
musicians my co-creators Allen Chang
great David Foster Oakland van der saw
Johann Carlson Jason Goldman Umberto
Gatica I tell me I'm not forgetting
anybody I don't want to forget anyone
you guys have all left a huge imprint on
me as a human being and as a musician
that has changed me and will change me
forever and lastly I just want to say
that the longer I live
the more I realize that love isn't free
love has a great cost the more you love
the more you hurt the greater chance
it's suffering in pain and when I woke
up this morning I thought about that
because I thought that for all of you
people all of those people that have
loved me and supported me through the
good times in the bad I would risk that
love a million times over for all of you
so thank you so much for this great
honor today